de quoi est ce qu'on va parler
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va parler
d'écosystèmes de marque je vous ai
beaucoup parlé de la marque au pot je
vous ai parlé notamment beaucoup ça
d'ailleurs c'est le compteur du nombre
d'abonnés qui change vous êtes 24 1428
sur instagram sauver venir nous
rejoindre c'est monsieur underscore gros
sur instagram
ça c'est dit je vous ai beaucoup parlé
d'eux au pot notamment au niveau des
smartphones le dernier en date dont je
vous ai parlé c'est celui-là c'est le au
port et nos quatre pros excellent
smartphone au pot m'a demandé de vous
parler de leurs écosystèmes j'ai trouvé
l'idée vachement intéressant propos est
une marque qui est en train de
développer son écosystème on a vu
arriver cette année leur première montre
connectés qui est juste ici à mon
poignet ces low power
pour moi il est très cool je vais tous
vous détailler chez au pot il ya plein
d'écouteurs différents et vous avez
notamment les encore x qui sont leurs
écouteurs les plus haut de gamme avec de
la réduction de bruit active et tout ça
fonctionne avec votre smartphone qui est
le centre de l'écosystème
alors chez oppose des smartphones y en a
plein phoenix de pro qui aujourd'hui le
plus haut de gamme de la marque mais
celui là il est vachement bien j'adore
son design ils aient accès au niveau de
la vidéo
il a un très bel écran incurvé un design
qui est vraiment hyper chouette je vous
invite à aller voir ma vidéo sur le réno
quatre pros qui est super il ya d'autres
smartphones y el reino 4 renault 4l dont
je vous parlerai d'ici quelques jours
donc avant de vous si ce n'est pas déjà
fait pour tout savoir de l'actuel quai
tout savoir également de l'attitude yovo
parce qu'on parle bien évidemment de au
pot mais parce que mais aujourd'hui on
va se concentrer sur l'écosystème au pot
on va regarder comment ils fonctionnent
pour reprendre les usages on va se
concentrer sur une journée un petit peu
standard la première chose que vous
faites si vous vous réveillez alors moi
cette montre je n'ai utilisé comme
réveil réveil matinal
vous programmez votre alarme la veille
au soir elle vous révélera avec une
alarme mais également une vibration vous
l'avez directement au poignet vous avez
café sur le bouton pour venir décalé un
petit peu votre alarme ou alors pour
l'arrêter directement sans autrement
vous avez également votre suivi de
sommeil vous voyez combien d'heures vous
avez dormi vous avez accès à vos
différentes phases de sommeil sous
permet d'avoir un reporting de votre
sommeil savoir si vous avez fait un gros
dodo ou pas pour savoir comment vous
habiller et sans avoir à ouvrir les
volets vous regarder sur votre
smartphone ou sur votre montre la météo
du jour en déjeunant
brossant les dents ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez écouter vos informations
vous l'actionner sur votre smartphone il
vous les écoutez dans vos écouteurs
notamment dans nos encore x comme ça
vous êtes au fait de ce qui se passe est
très pratiques comme les ans qu ils sont
des écouteurs à réduction de bruit
active vous pouvez écouter votre musique
vos infos tout ce que vous voulez dans
les transports en commun en marchant
dans la rue vous vous couper du monde
extérieur en actionnant la réduction de
bruit ça marche extrêmement bien mais
avec cet écosystème où va bien plus loin
puisque vous recevez et notamment vos
notifications dit mail directement sur
votre montre vous lisez peut-il vous
pouvez commencer à voir votre email mais
si vous voulez aller plus loin vous
n'avez qu'à appuyer sur un bouton pour
le consulter directement sur votre
smartphone ces pratiques sympa ça marche
bien dans cette idée d'écosystèmes on va
aller toujours plus loin on va venir à
voir ce triptyque en tout cas avec les
produits je vous présente tout de suite
votre smartphone au milieu vos écouteurs
pour tout entendre votre montre pour
tout piloter vous pouvez donc par
exemple y regarder un film une série sur
netflix sur youtube sur ce que vous
voulez vous visionner sur votre
smartphone si par exemple vous le posez
sur un trépied quoi que ce soit vous
n'êtes pas forcément envie de venir
toucher votre écran pour monter baisser
le volume
vous pouvez le faire directement depuis
votre montre play/pause montée bc volume
l'image et sur votre smartphone l'audio
et dans vos oreilles et vous pilotez
tout avec votre panier
c'est très pratique vous travaillez vous
avez ras le bol j'avais besoin de faire
un break
vous mettez vous en comics vous activer
les réductions bruit et vous vous évadez
vous relaxer et vous pouvez même grâce à
votre montre faire de la respiration
assistée pour vraiment me dire vous
détendre vous avez la musique
la respiration 6t vous êtes elle c'est
pratique et si dans la journée vous
laisser défaire du sport vous avez votre
programme d'entraînement directement
dans votre montre il ya moult
applications de pouvoir venir
télécharger sur le playstation et mais
en native directement dans votre monde
nous avons appliqué vachement sympa qui
vous permet de faire du sport en cinq
minutes pas plus pas moins très pratique
pour venir se redynamiser et faire sa
séance de sport quotidienne grâce au
capteur de rythme cardiaque présent
votre nom vous allez pouvoir maudite
aurez votre activité cardiaque savoir où
vous en êtes pendant l'exercice mais
également à la fin d'exercice pour voir
si tout s'est bien passé
il ya un côté aussi très pratique pour
le suivi de santé et lorsque vous
travaillez notamment en ce moment pour
tous le télétravail pouvait faire des
appels en visio avec vos collègues
depuis votre smartphone augmenter la
qualité grâce à vos en comics pour bien
les entendre et être
bien entendu et ça quel que soit
l'endroit où vous vous situez grâce à la
qualité du micro et à la réduction bruit
active et si à la fin de la journée vous
avez été extrêmement actifs et vous
comment ça manque un tout petit peu de
batterie vous avez de la recharge rapide
que ce soit pour votre montre pour votre
smartphone ou pour vos écouteurs pouvez
même venir recharger sans fil le soir
arrive et vous vous détendez devant une
série un film vous écoutez de la musique
faites ce que vous voulez ça ça vous
regarde je veux pas savoir
vous pouvez soit d'y reprogrammer une
nouvelle alarme le soir ou alors celle
que vous aviez déjà programmé la veille
est active pour lendemain n'avait donc
plus qu'à fermer vos yeux vous reposer
et laisser votre montre monitorer votre
sommeil
on a donc ici trois accessoires
complémentaires qui s'inscrivent dans un
écosystème
j'aime beaucoup la marque poésie noble
énormément c'est un très très gros
acteurs dans le monde de la tech grand
public ce soit au niveau du smartphone
au niveau de l'audio est également au
niveau de la montre nouvelle monde
collecté que je trouve super bien je
vous ai mis un petit fond pour venir
éclaté vos bulles si vous êtes un peu
stressé il ya un côté un peu déstressant
cette montre est disponible en deux
versions 41 à 46 mm ici c'est le 46 mm
que je vais avoir c'est un écran
flexible amoled 1,91 pousse à 326 p pays
avec une gamme de couleurs 100% de ces
ip 3 personnellement j'aime beaucoup
il ya un côté qui est extrêmement
premium avec cet écran incurvé c'est
plus immersif c'est vraiment très sympa
on tournait 6 sur webos les fans de
google seront satisfaits il ya vraiment
de quoi faire vous retrouvez deux
boutons son côté le premier vous
emmènera naviguer dans vos applications
suivi de sommeil rythme cardiaque du
sport la météo
vous en avez plein et surtout prévenir
en téléchargent et beaucoup d'autres sur
le ps store
mr oui si on tombe sur un os webos c'est
google vous avez donc un catalogue qui
est tout simplement énorme pour venir
télécharger toutes les applications qui
vous plaisent le bouton du dessous vous
servira pour le sport cours de fitness
course pour brûler des graisses marchand
planaire vélo en plein air natation on a
ici de la recharge rapide avec la groupe
couach
vous pouvez avoir en plus unie sim sur
la version 46 mm et uniquement sur la
version 46 mm il tourne avec un style
dragonne 3100 vous avez une autonomie
qui vous emmène jusqu'à 36 heures pour
votre monde 46 mm version bluetooth et
wifi et jusqu'à 21 jours en mode eco et
en 15 minutes de charge vous avez un
jour d'utilisation c'est mon petit
restantes à l'eau jusqu'à 50 mètres et 7
au pouvoir ceux disponibles au tarif de
249 euros 99 pour la version 41 mm et
pour la version 46 mm 329 euros 99
d'ailleurs si elle vous intéresse vous a
mis le lien en bas dans la description
les oncologues sont logés dans cette
boîte là
c'est extrêmement premium et surtout
lorsque vous l'aurez vous avez
effectivement tout une petite d'eau qui
s'y oppose mais ça on passe nous
intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse ici moi
surtout ce sont les différentes tailles
d'embouts c'est vraiment bien fait mais
surtout le plus intéressant se passe ici
vous retrouverez bien marquer au pot sur
le dessus ces écouteurs ont été co créé
avec dynaudio sacristain constructeur
danois trop ici système audio début 3.0
construction co axial vous avez deux
haut parleurs à l'intérieur le premier
haut parleur sans haut parleur à
membrane magnétique équilibré qui vous
servira pour leur fréquence est le
deuxième haut parleurs saint lô par leur
dynamique qui servira pour les moyennes
et pour les basses fréquences voilà donc
deux haut parleurs à l'intérieur le
codec ici six duels hdc en une réduction
relative grâce à deux micros présent sur
vos écouteurs vous avez donc retrouver
votre réduction brouille active un mode
transparent ils sont extrêmement
confortables avec ses petits embouts en
silicone
vous avez une transmission binaural en
bluetooth à faible latence et 6 et du
bluetooth 5.2 on a un peu plus de 5
heures d'écouté par écouteurs et lorsque
vous le mettez dans le bloc de charge et
bien vous monter jusqu'à 20 heures
d'écouté et ses écouteurs sont certifiés
ip54 résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
donc il ne craindront pas ni la pluie ni
la transpiration et vont trouver
également des commandes tactiles qui
vous permettront de faire play pause
raccrocher décrocher titres suivants
titres précédents mais également
d'activer votre réduction de bruit est
ici se connectent très facilement vous
n'avez qu'à ouvrir il se connecte vous
voyez votre niveau de batterie très
pratique j'aime beaucoup ces écouteurs à
réduction de bruit de au pot les encore
x coûte 179 euros s'il vous intéresse
vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description
voilà pour cet écosystème au pot ce
triptyque écouteurs montre smartphones
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez comment vous les trouvez ces
produits est ce qu ils peuvent vous
intéresser est-ce que vous avez déjà des
produits tshopo souvent on rentre dans
un écosystème par un smartphone et après
on vient compléter avec les accessoires
qu'on trouve autour
est ce que vous êtes déjà rentré dans
l'écosystème au pot est ce que vous avez
un produit éco système au pot sans
forcément avoir un smartphone
parce que bien évidemment ils sont
compatibles android mais en plus eyeos
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce qu'il vous
tente ce qui peut vous tentez qu'est ce
que vous pensez de pau et qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'évolution de la marque
avec tous ces produits qui arrivent dans
l'écosystème mark et moi ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on trouve très
rapidement pour continuer à parler de
pau avec le réno 4l reno kad z et
continue à parler tech bien évidemment
beaucoup d'amour des gros bisous et à
très vite
ciao
[Musique]
non
essai